[Music]
welcome thank you for coming I know this
is the first session the day after
conference party so it's not always
heavily packed but thank you for coming
my name is March Marnie I'm one of the
service program technical program
manager is looking after service at
Google and I'm - my sister I'm
engineering manager at Google how many
of you have been here a year ago when we
did the introductory or the announcement
of K native launch good numbers but we
have also fair amount of new faces and I
think that speaks to some of the
exciting momentum in a community around
K native so we will have a few slides
kind of talking about the momentum of
the project and and the kind of growth
of the community and definitely want to
dedicate some time on the end to
questions because usually this kind of
sessions spark fair amount of those so
the session is called a year K native a
year later but reality has really just
been nine months there's magic of
conference scheduling that happens there
and and what are exciting and very fun
ride that has been for us and I think
just watching the then from the
announcements to the growth has been
really really good so a year ago just
little flashback for those who have no
for those of you who have not been here
a year ago we talked about the fact that
already then in fact probably even
before then kubernetes was the de facto
platform for running containers at a lot
of different places like at that point
it was already hard to find cloud
service provider that was not offering
kubernetes as a service at that time and
that speaks through the kind of
profession of that of the platform
everywhere we also at the time when we
started kicking off thinking about key
native we're looking across the
community and we see we saw the numbers
13 here but frankly who knows how many
there really were out there different
projects there were focus on building
service offering or for the service
platform on top of kubernetes in an open
source community and the the interesting
part was that they were focusing a lot
of attention on very complex and and
kind of to some degree almost boring
that had to be addressed with regards to
running inside of kubernetes for
different types of workloads that
kubernetes was originally designed for
so in addition to kind of trying to
solve some of the user experience there
were there were had to address the the
building of images their routing
managing the scaling and stuff and stuff
like that
stuff that was not really exposed to the
user in a in a process of doing that in
a process of really building all these
new platforms because if you ask for
engineers to do something there'll be
five different ways to do it
they end up building very hard to
reproduce or not in portable solutions
that were there were hard to leverage
for the community so not only there were
the practic decreasing the portability
those projects by working together on
the same set of problems they were also
given that the resources the engineering
resources are limited they were not
investing a lot of attention towards
areas that the developer actually could
benefit from so the the overall
experience the new event sources the
different runtimes and so forth so we at
last next we announced Kay native as an
open source set of open source building
blocks for building a servlet solution
on kubernetes and I stress the building
blocks because initially we're really
focusing on make sure that each one of
those can be used independently to build
to allow developers to build products
for their developers and the initial set
of work was around Kay native buildings
eventing and serving so let's kind of
look where we are today today I'm happy
to announce that not only those building
blocks have been very successful and
continue evolving but there is now a
series of commercial offerings that are
based on top of Kay native building
blocks different companies that they're
listed over here including you might
have heard this week about the exciting
launch of cloud run and cloud run on gke
that we have talked about over here but
in addition to that there's number of
other commercial offerings both as a
service and as a product the different
companies use the components that Kay
native enables to build their offerings
on top of kubernetes
so let's go quickly and just overview
where we're where we are today I think
what I'm off what I'm talking about here
is set of features and capabilities that
we provide
there were available in a verse in a 0/5
release of K native which landed just
this week and in fact there is a block
that was published this morning that you
can kind of get a quick update on what
new features specifically around
eventing they were added over there but
in area of serving what are the benefits
for developer the first of all and and
the one that we hear the most about is
the notion of auto-scaling being able to
scale your application and respond to
unpredictable usage patterns so no
longer thinking about what my size of my
audience is going to be or going in
manually adding nodes but having that a
solution or the system that you're
building on top using K native
automatically scale and address the
demand but also when that's the demand
is no longer there being able to scale
to zero and and allow you to use the
resources in your kubernetes cluster for
other work that might be important at
that time so really greatly benefiting
the overall utilization of the cluster
the other important part that we talk
about a lot of times is the notion of
snapping both the configuration and the
code at the same time and being able to
reliably use it for individual
deployments which is great because you
know you write all perfect code but when
I have a bad and sometimes need to go
roll back to last previous no a previous
really known state or something some
version that I know actually works so
being able to manage revisions and
configuration as unit is critical for
that key native it comes with a very
powerful tour underneath is the East
your mesh network and sometimes it can
be pretty complex for developers so Kay
native exposes that as a set of very
simple set of api's they allows you to
manage things like request a request
path access control or being able to
expose certain metrics from that hto
mesh but not being able to not having
have to force force you to configure
this manually which can be complex at
times and there's a number of other
features the other part about
serving is that is very pluggable and
what we mean by that is that in in case
of Google what we've done is when we
build a kanay tucum potable service the
cloud run on GK in cloud run we can
integrate with native services that are
offered on GC p that offer things like
building so you can bring you can build
source code all the way to to container
or stock driver or other services for
data persistence and analytics in
addition to that is also extendable so
we've talked about number of partners
the two when a highlight over here is
get lab I think we have a session later
today that will highlight one of their
demos that use continuous deployment an
integration demonstration of how they
connect to the K net vaporize as well as
data dog for some of the metrics that
you can do in an alternative to star
driver so exciting things in serving in
build from the very beginning K native
was able to produce a offer reproducible
builds and that sounds very simple but
when you think about being able to rely
Rob reliably saris mooring some
struggling with English reliably built
images from the same code including
things like timestamps and others that
give you the same image over and over
again is something that I think if
you've done some builds yourself before
you quickly realize this not not easy
the other thing that that candidate
build provides a series of number of
pipelines or different language
optimized frameworks that can be used to
build directly from source and either
result in an image that then you
manually deploy or actually help you go
all the way from source to URL to live
active URL all of that is done on a
cluster so there is no need for darker
locally there's no need for cross
compiling so if you're working on a Mac
or Windows and you need to build an
image that's gonna run on Linux which
can ativ runs today on you you don't
have to deal with those remember all the
extra flags and how to do that and some
of the language is dynamic language for
example might have to benefit from that
too and because this is running as a
service is running under clusters
running on top of kubernetes you're
benefiting from a lot of the elasticity
and
being able to use the resources when you
need them and and dedicate in them
dedicated those resources something else
when you don't again loosely coupled you
will see that the theme across every one
of the components of K native so in this
case integrates with number of different
CI CD tools I think if you've attended
the cloud run solutions yesterday I
demonstrated at cloudbuilt integration
we have Jenkin eggs a number of others
including a new foundation they were
launched specifically to kind of focus
on that that leverages the key native
project originally launched in Canada is
the continuous from the build foundation
and there is growing number of
enterprise tool tools that are kind of
popping up here that provide some very
specific set of features for enterprise
use cases like policy management logging
and so forth so again so serving built
and now last but not least always
eventing for some reason ends upon II
and I don't know why that's the case we
need to flip the order sometimes so
eventing super exciting a set of add-ons
in a 0/5 release that we just launched
this week kind of adding to the very
primitive set of objects that we have
under head underneath and adding some
easier to use constructs like broker and
trigger that developers can easily just
use by the leveraging some of the
defaults that canada fall ready expose
what k native eventing does by default
is helps you really orchestrate the
event sources and events both on the
clusters was off the coaster it it
provides a very declarative way of
binding to event sources and and
connecting them to to either directly
some consumer of those of those sources
but also building very complex set of
pipelines that the chicken and those
little pipelines get in more interesting
and interesting as people get creative
with how you can leverage those
capabilities because it runs on key
native and it's not just a brand-new set
of things it just leverages the key
native architecture and components its
scale you're getting the exact same
scalability and outer scaling
capabilities that you've seen in serving
so you can build things that are very
nominal in a resource utilization when
you first deploy them and you use them
but
being automatically address a larger
number of events when you need to and
all of that is based with regards to
transport on standards cloud events for
for kind of packaging the events so what
that means that we are able to attach
ourselves to an um number of other
different projects and and event sources
that generate events in this new open
standard for events again loosely
coupled or extendable so you can bind to
existing event sources there's probably
28 23 or something like that of
different I know I went down I should go
the list grows all the time and you can
see that list full list of existing
event sources that you don't have to
build you can just consume on key native
website but we also provide a very easy
way of extending those and there's a
whole session later today SRV 3:05 that
you can come to this dedicated
explicitly to the new eventing sources
and villa is going to talk about the new
business object models hopefully no
business and and share some of the
hands-on way of building new event
sources alright so there was about the
capabilities of can ad let's talk about
community frankly we could not have done
this ourselves and there is a pretty
fascinating community already behind key
natives starting with the launch
partners a year nine months ago
so let's overview today again 0/5
already landed our community has 49 50 I
think more now since yesterday this
numbers are probably from Friday I think
50 different companies that are
contributing to K native 3.7 thousand
over 3.7 thousand different pull
requests the number of contributors and
what I mean by contributors is not only
people who write code but also people
who review code people who write
documentation four hundred plus of those
the one interesting number here is also
we have now spun up nine different work
groups so these are kind of specific
area interest groups that are like you
know what I I cannot understand the
entirety native but in an area of
auto-scaling I think
contribute and I can I can be valuable
resource and people from number of
different companies including those
who'd never write code that contribute
that's contributed to okay native come
in and join us on that the number of
them I am most interested about though
probably most proud of is that the
momentum it wasn't just when we launched
it it continued being sustained so I
built this kind of 20 percent month or a
month number by aggregating the pool
requests the issues the comments the
slack channel participation worker
participation just seeing this this line
growing Thomas is going to talk a little
later about what that means in
engineering terms is just fascinating
alright
the other interesting number with
regards to community is that yeah Google
was there in a beginning and some of
their launch partners and we are
extremely thankful for those partners
and their participation in that but the
just the long tail of companies that are
now contributing to 2k native is
something that speaks to the health of
the project one-fifth of all
contributions to key native are done by
the broad community people who have less
than 15 different PRS I think at this
point there's linked to life stats so
these numbers change all the time you
can look it up but that's just
fascinating that this long tail of
contributors drives really the momentum
because different companies getting
involved in this project means that the
number of use cases that they address is
also growing and that drives features
back into key native which speaks
further to the capabilities that we can
deal with this I'm gonna hand it to
Thomas to talk about engineering
thank you much thanks mark super
exciting to see so many companies
contribute to the system and I think it
speaks to how useful these small
primitives that we have built how how
useful these companies find these
primitives we see a lot of momentum in K
native and and we talked a lot about
open source but we see this in customer
growth we see these in partners
launching services on top okay native
and we see it in the number of
contributors to the project and the
amount of code they write so just in the
last quarter we had 228 people
contributing to K native and these folks
wrote
1,500 PRS that's five times more than
what we had in q2 2018 so amazing growth
and my team at Google we're writing a
lot of this around 61% we can plan to
continue investing in K native to keep
this acceleration going in the next year
but as an engineering manager you know
that you're selecting a bunch of code
it's not enough to have a healthy
open-source project there's a lot of
other things you have to do so what we
have done as well is to grow up as an
open-source community we have created
the steering committee that's in charge
of the overall health and long-term
sustainability of the project and we
have recently invited non-google members
to the steering committee this is how we
create the but robust ecosystem it can't
be a single vendor when we have 50
companies that are partnering in for a
shared goal we have a technical
oversight committee that's doing a
similar thing from a technical
perspective other things that we have
done is related to this promise of
portability we want to make sure that
code you write 4k native will work on
course on cloud run but it also works in
Canada open-source in your own data
center or on a competitor and the way we
do this is to clearly clearly define the
expectations of the system and have
tests that verify that the
implementations meet those those
specifications I also want to highlight
that we have software engineers working
on K native but we also have folks
working on testing infrastructure
documentation samples etc I'm really
proud about how solid the engineering
work is on Canada and how good our
releases are we my team knows that I'm a
stickler for flaky tests I really don't
like flaky tests and for a long time we
had 0% flaky tests which wasn't true
because it rounded down so it was
actually 0.04 percent test flakes but it
was still what you need if we have 200
people from 50 companies contributing
code and you and want to have any
surance that that code actually works
you need to have a really really solid
test infrastructure and that's something
we have invested in a lot yeah similarly
we have a team writing documentation and
samples so that your developers at your
companies can read how to get started
okay native from a developer point of
view and from a contributor point of
view so what do we get with four hundred
contributors and thousands four thousand
pull requests well we have done a lot
over the last year it's pretty
incredible to think that just a year ago
less than a year ago is when we briefed
a few partners under MDA at cube colony
in Copenhagen and nine months ago we
launched at cloud next and we've got a
lot of excitement which is great we were
super excited to see that we hit we hit
the nerve a lot of people had been
thinking about the same thing and they
wanted someone to come in and really
really rally the community around the
shared goal but we also got a lot of
criticism and that's even better because
that means that people care about what
you're doing and we took this criticism
to heart so we spent quite a lot of time
between 0 1 and 0 2 to re architect the
system to make it more flexible and more
pluggable so that partners can fit this
into the environment where they're
working so at 0.2 we sort of had the
foundation in place to have something
really useful and the project shifted at
that point from addressing partner needs
infrastructure needs architecture to
addressing customer needs and we saw
that in 0.3 we had the support for the
container resource pack and this is
largely driven by requests for GPUs and
TP use a lot of people want to run
machine learning models or machine
learning serving on K native and GPUs
make that a lot cheaper people wanted to
run private K native services rather
support for private or public services
so you can do depending on your fronting
is open to the public your back-end is
hidden and you don't want that to be
accessible to the to the broader
Internet and of course improves
auto-scaling improves scale to zero all
those things
at this point we also change to change
our release model so we're now every six
weeks cutting in your release and that's
how we get features out to customers
quickly of course bug fixes security
fixes goes out every week but major
changes goes out every six weeks and
this allows us to take feedback from
customers
so in 0.4 the feedback had shifted a
little bit from 0.3 0.3 was okay we
couldn't we can't do what we need to do
0.4 was hey I'm running K native and it
turns out that upgrading to the next
version of K native which by the way you
now had to do every six weeks is really
annoying it takes a lot of time so we
spent a lot of time between 0 3 and 0 4
to make that into a seamless experience
for people running on top of K native
and also because we're on cane ad
services ourselves cloud run and G key
and cloud run and we want to make sure
that those systems can upgrade smoothly
as well we also added more support for
things we hear from enterprises they are
really careful about how they manage
secrets for how they authenticate to
other services kubernetes has support
for this we forward the support into K
native similarly once you start
architecting system with a front-end and
private backends you want to have a
really efficient communication channel
so we added support for HTTP 2 and grps
so get G RPC sorry so that you can have
this efficient communication channel
between your micro services yeah and now
yes last week we cut it announced it
today sir point 5 gr PC streaming and
then a big overhaul in eventing so
really really huge improvements there
115 today we're gonna do a deep dive
into K native eventing and and I really
recommend that that session so I'm gonna
invite Ryan Gregg up on stage and he's
gonna talk about how you can use K
native on Google cloud to make your
developers more productive for your
business good morning okay so I'm Ryan
Greg I'm a product manager on the
surplice team at Google
and this week we were really excited to
announce the launch into beta for both
cloud run and cloud on gke I'm not below
begging for people to play last year
when I you know when I announced cañedo
I got applause for building hello world
and docker so like I'm I'm author for it
so clog quadrant caught on gke
these are our managed cane ativ
offerings and cloud run is a fully
managed service platform for running
containers on Google service
infrastructure so you get the kanay
native API you get the K native runtime
contract but you don't have to worry
about the cluster or any of the
implementation details under the covers
or even what version of K native you're
running you just get to call the API
deploy a container and go and the best
part about cloud run is that it's pay
for use you only have to pay for the
time that the request is being processed
and the rest of the time when we scale
the service down or even if we don't
it's free cloud or non gke gives you a
lot more flexibility though it's
actually running the K native
open-source components along with some
additional work on top of your
kubernetes engine cluster so you can go
in and use the K native API to deploy
workloads you can use the great UI and
CLI that we offer through G cloud and
through cloud console or you can go into
the API and do all the kubernetes stuff
that you're used to being able to do you
can access the K native API directly you
can program sto under the covers to add
policies to the workloads that you're
deploying and you can take advantage of
the additional resources that are
available in gke like more memory more
CPU types GPUs and TPU accelerators all
the greatness of compute that is
available on kubernetes engine and then
of course you can use K native anywhere
so in addition to the manage products
through anthos or on Prem offering and
on basically any kubernetes cluster
anywhere of course you can run K native
and have a great story for being able to
use our service experience across all
three environments so wherever you go
you can have a great service experience
we also have a bunch of customers who
have been using this on the Alpha
program and it's been really exciting to
see the workloads that they have built
for example we worked with the aerial or
Airbus aerial it's
an alpha test on cotton on gke and they
use it for doing real-time processing of
imagery that comes from drones airplanes
and satellites to help understand the
impact of disaster areas and be able to
respond quickly and they're really
excited about the the way that this
service platform scales because as it
turns out you can't really predict when
natural disasters are going to happen
and you need to be able to respond
really quickly and have the
infrastructure scale up underneath it
and with Claude Ron and Claude on gke
they really saw some great benefits for
being able to respond to natural
disasters when they occurred so those
are our two different ways of running
managed K native on top of Google Cloud
we're really excited to see what
everybody is going to be building on top
of them in addition to how you continue
to use the K native open-source project
thanks Thomas thanks mark really
exciting to see that to summarize what
we talked about so far so mark started
by talking a little bit about what K
Native does and how it can make your
developers more productive then we
talked a little bit about the broad
uptake in the open source community and
how we're trying to foster a really
healthy long-term sustainable community
for K Native I talked a little bit about
what we did last year and and I want to
just give a hint or what we see
happening in the immediate future for K
native so we just cut 0.5 and 0.5 is a
great milestone but the real important
milestone is 1.0 that's when people can
put their mission critical business
critical logic on top of K native and
quite honestly we're not there just yet
so where I see the team going and the
community going is that we really need
to double down on get to 1.0 what we
have right now is super useful it has
enough functionality to be a really
viable product but we don't really have
the performance and stability just yet
that you can put your 1.0 brand behind
the other thing we need to focus on is
to get an API that we're comfortable
standing behind for years we have made
some changes throughout the last year
based on customer feedback that's why
you have a 0.1 0.2 0.3 right we're
bringing those changes
and we have a really focused working
group right now to get the 1.0 api draft
out and if you're interested in
contributing we really value feedback in
these working groups and they're open to
the public and if you go to our github
page you can see how you can join these
meetings I touched a little bit on
specifications and and the broader term
there we call it conformance Ryan was
talking about K native anywhere that
only works if we have a robust set of
conformance and conformance tests that
we can run to make sure that this K
native deployment is conformant with
with the K native standard yeah that's a
big focus for the team if you really
love writing tests we have worked for
you just ping me and and I'll send you a
bunch bunch of tester on to write so
these are things that that we're doing
of course we're going to continue to
address customer feedback we're going to
continue to add features but that's not
the biggest focus in the project right
now the biggest focus is to get to 1.0
because in my mind that's when the fun
starts that's when people start using
your things that's when you have a
customer the big big customer growth and
the reason we're doing this is because
we want to help other people be more
productive in this business and yeah
that doesn't really happen until we get
to GA and one below so we talked a
little bit about last year we're saying
that kubernetes was becoming the de
facto platform for running server
running containers and the last year Kay
native didn't exist I hope now through
the keynotes and the samples and the
products that Google has launched plus
the five other products other cloud
providers have launched we have
convinced you that Kay native is
becoming the de facto star platform for
running servers and kubernetes with that
we have a little bit of time oh yeah we
have talked a lot about Kennedy I
highlighted a few sessions here we
mentioned that there's a que native
eventing SVR 3:05 coming this afternoon
at 1:15 p.m. these other sessions will
be
available on YouTube to watch in case
you missed them we're at the tail end of
the conference so so so it's too late to
go over to them now but you can watch
them with YouTube I recommend double
speed it's the way to do it when we talk
yeah yeah yeah so thank you so much this
is how you can contact us please join
the open source community join be you
can be one of a thousand people in a
slack channel it's it's beautiful and
and thank you so much for all of the
people in the room who might have
contributed and the industry partners
that have 40 minutes to make this this
successful and now with club on now with
cloud run being generally available to
everybody you can easily just take it
for a spin
data available to the public it's easily
available on GCPs it's not generally
available it's available yeah there you
go you can easily try it that's how
about that
using this cloud run URL there
[Music]